the cdc has put out guidelines for
celebrating thanksgiving safely among
the recommendations
enjoy your feast outside and if you're
hosting tell guests to
bring their own food and forks the cdc
putting out a sketch of what that might
look like
a bunch of people bundled up in the cold
huddled around a fire all wearing masks
and standing far apart hardly the image
that usually comes to mind for a
happy thanksgiving dave rubin is the
host of the
reuben report dave good to see you i
want to put the rest of those cdc
guidelines up on the screen because
they're worth looking at it says bring
your own
food drinks plates cups and utensils
wear a mask and safely store your mask
while eating and drinking
avoid going in and out of the areas
where food is being prepared
use single-use options and disposable
items like
condiment packets and plates your
thoughts on
three families showing up with three
turkeys in some cases dave
you know thanksgiving which is literally
the most american holiday there is which
is about
being thankful for the freedom that we
have and all of the goodness that this
country has given to
us is about exercising your freedom
that's the purpose
of the holiday and the idea that the cdc
wants people that you're living in the
northeast in the winter
to stand outside and you should have
masks inside and people are bringing
their own cutlery and utensils and all
these things first off they know that
virtually no one's going to do it
but it's sort of this ever encroaching
move to see what they can
force us or at least trick us into doing
in our own
homes which in many ways is the most
anti-american thing possible that's not
to diminish
kovid but covet is a disease with a 97
to 99.5
recovery rate and now we have these
vaccines that are going to say
you know that are going to take care of
95 percent of people on top of that so
you know in this case i'm one of the
people that's just more on
the freedom side of this you should do
what you think is right but i guarantee
you that whitmer the governor of
michigan and newsom my governor here in
california and cuomo in new york
they ain't going to be doing any of
these things at their parties i
guarantee you they won't
no nuisan might be at the french laundry
you know you talk about the weather
being cold in the northeast i think it's
39 degrees is the high there today dave
and
you know it's interesting because some
of the regulations we put up on the
screen from the cdc are even tougher
in new york state by governor cuomo and
one of the sheriffs in fulton county new
york
had this to say about enforcement watch
in this particular case when we go into
somebody when when you try to authorize
by executive order that we can come into
somebody's house
count the people and take some sort of
action that
that remedy is greater than the wrong
having people gather
yeah remedy greater than the wrong your
thoughts
god bless that guy that is absolutely
right and by the way that's the way we
fight back
against these authoritarian rules is by
good people who are in law enforcement
private citizens
just saying enough is enough just
because the powers that be
tell us we can't have family in our
homes during thanksgiving and we have to
do all of these things
doesn't mean that they have some
god-given right to to make it be
and when when we step up and say hey
we'll take care of our families
accordingly
and if you're a store owner and you want
to say hey you have to have a mask in my
store
but you can do what you want outside
that's called personal responsibility
that's
that's the building block of america
which again is exactly what we're
supposed to be celebrating on
thanksgiving
you know what i found fascinating is the
wall street journal had a story
yesterday talking about the fact that we
still don't know where people are
getting sick
five percent maybe from restaurants 10
from travel up to 50 to 75 percent they
have no
idea how people are getting the disease
and yet we have all these various
mandates that are just
kind of throwing spaghetti against the
wall your final thoughts dave
well that's an absolutely great point
what a responsible government would be
doing is saying hey
when we've done these specific things
then we see certain numbers change but
we don't really see that they basically
just say oh we go from one crisis and
one set of rules
to another crisis let's not forget march
two weeks to flatten the curve
and we're basically at the end of 2020
right now that's nine months and do you
sense they they are going to let this
thing end
doesn't seem like it yeah final note we
should you know florida is
has none of these mandates or very few
of these mandates and they're not doing
well
as far as covet goes but illinois
wisconsin
other states that have severe mandates
you know doing worse than florida dave
rubin it's always good to see you thank
you sir appreciate it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell